oh  McDonald's  that's an ad that's supposed to appeal  to adults not even just adults on acid  but sober adults too the initial  excitement that these grown adults felt  over their Happy Meals has apparently  given way though to disappointment and  not disappointment in themselves for  being so pathetic and emotionally  stunted as to order a damned happy meal  for themselves in the first place but  disappointment over the toys in the box  there were so many directions McDonald's  could have gone with the toys that would  have felt special Ninja Turtle toys to  be clear that is an adult a grown man  upset that his Happy Meal didn't come  with a Ninja Turtle toy I'll even eat  Happy Meals I will eat Happy Meals as an  adult but I eat them when I order them  for my kids and I steal half of the meal  before handing the box back to them in  the car  like a civilized and mature adult  okay that's the correct strategy